hawaii is one of the remote places on
the planet
and in the open ocean there are no
landmarks
so hawaii was discovered by canoes with
no gps no motors no electronics
uh just pure nature and that's what
we're uh so we're doing today to
celebrate that
around hokulea
she is a replica of a
polynesian voyaging canoe
they were
the mode of transportation for
discovering the hawaiian islands
there's no metal there's no screws
there's no nails there's no braces that
hold the canoe together it's nothing but
lashings a rope
there's no motors on board there's no
navigation equipment that we use to go
across the ocean
we started in hawaii in end of may 2014
we embarked on this worldwide voyage
which first ended up going towards
tahiti through our ancestral routes and
now we're here in martha's vineyard
a big part of this voyage right malama
honua is to train a whole cadre
of young navigators and captains
wait now we'll leave the back sail let's
get the 23 out
a big foresail
khalil wong
is one of the apprentice navigators i've
done four voyages with him
and he was on his own across the
atlantic ocean and he was brilliant i
mean he was just so successful you know
after traveling like 1200 miles finding
just little islands in the middle of
nowhere you're talking like thousands of
hours
of observation at sea
when we were navigating the open ocean
our biggest clue that tells us where we
are and where we're going is the sun
the sun as we know rises in the east and
sets in the west so if we just know
where one point of is then we know where
everything else is
the stars do us the same thing it's like
the compass in the sky we memorize close
to 200 stars and know where they rise
and where they set and how they move
across the sky
the sun and the stars and everything
work in conjunction with the swells
so in the absence of the sun
then you maintain the orientation of the
crew to those small patterns that's a
very difficult thing
the hokulea was built with the express
purpose of proving that navigation by
the ancient way was very viable these
canoes could be guided over 2 000 miles
in long distances
they proved that on their very first
voyage in 1976.
what it means is continuation kaleo and
these others they're just like a pinch
of salt as far as the people who know
how to do this type of navigation
you